did you ever meet the other five guys
who were in Nirvana before you playing
DRS Dr some of them yeah are they bitter
I don't think well I haven't seen them
in a long time one I I remember meeting
one of them and he shows up in a monster
truck over at the house where Kurt and I
lived he's like hey let's go get some
beers and we went down to this is Aber
or this is Olympia Washington we went to
a grocery store and next door there was
a laundry mat he goes hey y'all got a
quarter go yeah he jumps in an
industrial siiz dryer and goes put the
quarter in and he just he got in the
dryer and just flipped around a couple
minutes and then knocked on the window
we let him out oh my good it's kind of
like the Pete best story I would love to
meet the five other guys who were in
Nana and what they're doing now wouldn't
you wouldn't that be sort of an
interesting I know two of them Chad I
think um was the drummer right before me
Chad lives on I think he lives in
Banbridge Island and he's really you
know he's got a his own music thing
going and he's happy they should form a
band five drummers all together just a
sit there like some sort of I don't know
some kind of drumming thing well the
other one uh Dale crover the guy who
played drums on the first Nirvana record
he and Chad both played but he was like
my drumming hero so and he's he's on the
cover of modern drummer and why was he
not good enough did you ever ask Kurt he
was in another band he was in Kurt's
favorite band and Kurt would borrow him
sometimes oh I see so he didn't want to
leave his favorite band meanwhile he
should have left that favorite band
favorite band The Melvin so Dave I don't
understand something about you I don't
understand how you became this great
guitar player you were in Nirvana you
were the drummer yeah and then all of a
sudden now you're this front man with a
guitar and I don't understand how you
made that transition so when Nirvana
ends were you so wealthy at that point
that you could have stopped everything
never for you could have right because I
when I think of Nirvana I think of
Nirvana money for a second it had to be
insane three guys touring you didn't
really tour that much but the records
you sold a lot of records sold a lot of
records and I guess there was enough
money there that you could have lived
the rest of your life yeah I mean at
that point I was I was 24 or 25 years
old I'd never made more than $325 an
hour you know what were you worth I
don't really even remember $100 million
oh no way $50 million no not $25 million
not that much either $15 million maybe
all right so somewhere around $15
million you were worth it's true you
could have just said you like that
that's a that's that's high ball too
wish I was in Nirvana yeah what were you
doing out High School you maniac I was
working at a music you're over at that
you're over at that Junior College
wasting time so now all of a sudden I
would look at it as Freedom I've got 15
million in the bank and if I go and do
some music now there's no risk yeah at
least I've got my you honestly that's
one of the I mean the foundation of this
band is so perfect because everything
that we've done we've never had this
financial this aggressive Financial with
foood Fighters yeah like we've always
just been mellow like let's make it
about the music let's not talk about
money let's just go have a good time and
um what do you mean not talk about money
I mean Taylor wants to talk about money
he doesn't have 15 million in the bank
well you know also all of these albums
that we've put out they they're on my
label and I just license them to Sony
BMG oh is that it yeah and so we own our
whole catalog so no like nobody tells us
how to do
stuff